to have the world's population their
life essential to the companies that
sell them they're a global market worth
about 38 billion dollars period products
and access to them has a major impact on
women's well-being and in a move that is
said that it said was fundamental to
equality and dignity this year Scotland
passed a law to provide free Sanitary
products to all of its citizens Roxanna
severi went to Scotland to meet the
women who make it happen
you wanna know for half the world's
people period products are a necessity
but with cause soaring to roughly 11 a
month for many women they've become a
luxury this is our time of the month uh
kits and within that in this Warehouse
near Edinburgh the social Enterprise hey
girls is trying to change that so these
are some of the products that are
getting handed out for free yes exactly
so we've got in October a new law made
Scotland the first country in the world
to offer tampons and sanitary pads to
anyone who needs them for free a move
aimed at ending period poverty hey girls
manufacturers some of those products we
Define period poverty as having to
choose between a packet of period
products and say something like a packet
of pasta or some other you know basic
necessity be it you know energy or food
and when people can't afford period
products they tend to opt for obviously
food and energy so it means going
without what you need for your period
the World Bank says globally 500 million
women and girls lack access to menstrual
products in the U.S the 2019 study in St
Louis found two-thirds of low-income
women couldn't afford period products
and in Scotland a survey found a quarter
of school girls and women have struggled
to access sanitary supplies what kind of
consequences can that have on their
lives they might not be able to leave
the house that means missing out on days
at work if they do choose to go out and
to the workplace or to an interview
they're going to have to use something
that's substandard even things like
bread bread bread so a lot of really
unsafe unhygienic and you know
pure quality items that's one reason
lawmaker Monica Lennon proposed the
legislation in 2019. what was the
response especially from the men yeah I
think there were some red faces I think
some people feel awkward about it but I
think that just shows that we need that
culture change where we normalize
discussion around menstruation
the government has helped hey girls
launch this app showing where to collect
the free products at pharmacies schools
universities and public buildings
in this neighborhood of Glasgow women
are directed to this public library to
pick up their free Sanitary products and
inside in the bathrooms this is what
they'd find we have got four Super
tampons for regular tampons no one knows
what's inside this is
exactly yeah the packs are proving so
popular demand is doubling every month
says Lauren Heaney of the homeless
charity the Simon community so do you
think this is a program that should be
replicated in other countries yeah
definitely it's not a hard project to to
replicate it's really simple and the
benefit that it brings to people is
really fantastic in the U.S some cities
and states have started giving out free
period products in public schools and
colleges South Africa
South Korea and New Zealand have taken
similar steps we don't want any student
to miss school particularly because they
don't have access to period products but
not on a national scale like Scott
Scotland for the campaigners behind the
country's new law free tampons and
sanitary pads are about human rights and
dignity it's about women and girls being
valued and been respected as a second oh
and it sends out that message that
periods are normal and that access to
period products should be normal too for
CBS Saturday morning Roxanna saberi
Edinburgh Scotland